I've been I think positively surprised
by the intense and positively on the
place I think the business community is
ready to make a difference I think the
Prime Minister's speech today helped but
what I'd really like to see I'd like to
see the government supporting that
intent here and luck see the government
more proactively more positively and
importantly publicly come out and say we
support business small and big
businesses the lifeblood of the economy
here that's well how we're going to
improve people's lives and you know I
think that's really the intent of a lot
of what I'm hearing here today so you're
saying the Prime Minister's been a bit
too look warm towards UK business thus
far I think the voice of business has
really been sorely lacking here for a
while and business has a social purpose
that's got every social good and I think
it needs positive statements of intent
supporting business and all the players
and society as well because business is
what lifts the economy the economy is
what lifts people's lives it's part of
the problem do you think that many
business leaders are too absorbed with
brexit and what it's going to mean for
their business I think too much of the
UK is blinded by Brixton and it applies
to the business community regulators
politicians as well and I think if you
have a look where we are we the
Industrial Revolution started on this
wonderful place and you've got FinTech
and you've got technology as a whole the
UK can become a real hub for these
things but not in terms of account
structure not in terms of the current
regulation and we need to look at that
and say this is part of our place in the
world now one of the big themes here of
conference today is disruption you at
the helm of a three hundred and twenty
two year business how on earth do you
drive technological innovation in a
company like that with a lot of
difficulty I mean you write with 322
years old and what we've said is we want
to compete we want to disrupt we've
taken our digital business outside and
and we're just hiring different people
we see ourselves very much as an
insurance company as a tech firm and
there's a company look into the future I
see ourselves as a 322 year old
disrupt that now we've just had a rise
in interest rates is that going to
change the complexion of the UK business
for you interest rates rising a bit over
time as good for savers we haven't very
we've got a huge savings business it's
actually good economically for business
like I say as well and so a gradual rise
and interest rates is generally a very
positive thing for industry things like
annuities as well if interest rates rise
a bit more annuities are standing to
look pretty attractive again this is
well signal to the market let's see how
it works but we need to be cautious on
this we've got a tough a couple of years
economically and we just need to watch
it and be cautious on it and I think
we'll probably the one the state of the
markets right now I mean it doesn't seem
to be a day goes by with that the S&P
500 or the Nasdaq or the footsie all the
DAX
it's in a new record high the markets
getting a bit topic if you ever look at
valuations in the u.s. that toppy the
Trump trade got everyone excited that's
going around a bit but yeah they're
getting pretty top you've got a spree
top as well
Europe's had some decent bin flows into
it the UK has been about mixed etch in
the last few months you've seen outflows
out of the equity markets and it's in
the UK is looking pretty cheap versus
some other markets particularly in
financials and that's I guess a bit of a
fear over break serve and what happens
economically if we can get a bit of
certainty on brexit and if you can get
some things happening you might find
that part of the market bounces back as
well